dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here today we
are going to talk some more about fluid
simulations and fluid guiding helya as
you know all too well it is possible to
simulate the laws of fluid motion on a
computer make a digital scene and create
absolutely beautiful videos such as the
ones you see here newer and newer
research papers show up to both extend
the possible scenarios that we can
simulate and there are also other works
to speed up already existing solutions
this piece of work introduces a
technique that mathematicians like to
call the primal-dual optimization method
this helps us accomplish two really cool
things one is fluid guiding fluid
guiding is a problem where we are
looking to exert control over the fluid
while keeping the fluid flow as natural
as possible I have written my master
thesis on the very same topic and can
confirm that it's one hell of a problem
the core of the problem is that if we
use the laws of physics to create a
fluid simulation we get what would
happen in reality as a result however if
we wish to guide this piece of fluid
towards a target shape for instance to
form an image of our choice we have to
both retain natural fluid flows but
still create something that would be
highly unlikely to happen according to
the laws of physics for instance a
splash of water is unlikely to suddenly
form a human face of our choice the
proposed technique helps this ambivalent
goal of exerting a bit of control over
the fluid simulation while keeping the
flows as natural as possible there are
already many existing applications of
fluids and smoke in movies when an actor
fires a gun and the fire and smoke
plumes are added to the footage in
post-production
however with a high quality fluid
guiding technique we could choose target
shapes for these smoke plumes and
explosions that best convey our artistic
vision and number two it also
accomplishes something that we call
separating boundary conditions which
prevents imprecisions where small fluid
volumes are being stuck to walls
the guiding process is also followed by
an upsetting step where we take a course
simulation and artificially synthesized
sharp high-frequency details onto it
computing the more detailed simulation
would often take days without such
synthesizing techniques kind of like
with wavelet turbulence which is an
absolutely incredible paper that was
showcased in none other than the very
first two minute papers episode link is
in the video description box don't watch
it it's quite embarrassing and all this
leads to i popping lee beautiful
solutions Wow I cannot get tired of this
in the paper you will find much more
about breaking dams tornado simulations
and applications of the primal-dual
optimization method normally to remain
as authentic to the source materials as
possible I don't do any kind of
slow-motion and other similar
shenanigans but this time I just
couldn't resist it have a look at this
and I hope you'll like the results
hmm if you feel the alluring call of
fluids I've put some resources in the
video description including a general
description I wrote on the basics of
fluid simulation and fluid control with
source code both on the CPU and GPU and
the link to Doyle kim's amazing book
that I'm currently reading highly
recommended if you also have some online
tutorials and papers that help you
solidify your understanding of the topic
make sure to leave a link in the
comments I'll include the best ones in
the video description if you would like
to see more episodes like this one make
sure to subscribe to two minute papers
we would be more than happy to have you
along on our journey of science thanks
for watching and for your generous
support now see you next time
[Music]
[Music]